el suspenso se ha apoderado de abu dhabi
para el último gran premio de la
temporada esta ciudad emiratí se alista
para vivir el duelo final entre el
británico lewis hamilton y el neerlandés
max verstappen por el título de la
presente temporada de fórmula uno al
estar los dos rivales empatados en
puntos la carrera de este domingo será
decisiva y promete una batalla que ya
emociona los espectadores
yo creo que va a ser muy cerrado pero
también una experiencia única será
recordado en los próximos años como algo
muy especial el software
de todo está abierto es un escenario de
terror pero el más emocionante que se
puede imaginar
pero hay mucho en juego si gana hamilton
a los 36 años será su octavo título de
su carrera uno más que el laureado
michael schumacher maks está luchando
por su primer título a la edad de 24
años a lo largo de la temporada la
tensión entre ambos ha ido en aumento
con intercambios verbales e incluso
choques en la pista ante este panorama
los comisarios han advertido sobre el
riesgo de suspensión o el retiro de
puntos en caso de comportamiento
antideportivo si ninguno de los dos
termina la carrera o no consiguen puntos
de la temporada sería max verstappen
porque ha ganado una carrera más que
hamilton este año